quels sont les clichés qu'on peut avoir
sur les insectes mais il y a des
insectes qui sont quand même
désagréables les mouches qui font caca
partout et puis qui amène des maladies
souvent des araignées c'est pas beau ça
ça fait peur
de tout ce qui est volant par rapport à
la peur des piqûres combattre les idées
reçues une des missions de l'office pour
les insectes et leur environnement en
2017 s'est association a créé la maison
des insectes à carrière sous Poissy pour
permettre au public d'admirer de près
ces petites bêtes méconnues phasmes
fourmis ou papillons une cinquantaine
d'espèces sont présentées objectif
apprendre à s'émerveiller pour
démystifier l'univers obscur de ses
êtres vous revenez avec plein d'apriori
si je vous montre certaines blattes vous
allez trouver si vous savez pas que ce
sont des blattes la plupart du temps
vous allez avoir une réaction
d'étonnement vous allez regarder vous
allez observer vous allez vous dire ah
c'est plutôt joli puis une fois qu'on
vous dit que c'est une blague vous avez
un mouvement de recul donc ça vous
montre quoi ça vous montre que c'est pas
la blague qui est sale mais c'est l'idée
que vous en avez
prédateur naturel recyclent des matières
organiques ou pollinisateurs les
insectes ont une place centrale dans les
écosystèmes les trois quarts de la
diversité de notre nourriture et
directement liée à ces êtres vivants
quand vous reprenez une pomme et que
vous observez le cul de la pomme vous
avez ce qui reste d'une fleur et cette
pomme elle serait pas aussi belle et
certainement pas aussi grosse s'il y a
pas s'il y a pas mal d'insectes
notamment des abeilles sauvages qui
étaient passées visiter les fleurs nous
notre rôle c'est bien ça c'est de
réussir à faire prendre conscience à
tout le monde que les insectes ils ont
une place qui est extrêmement importante
dans le fonctionnement de la nature que
nous on ne fait partie de la nature
qu'on peut pas vivre sans la nature et
qu'on peut donc pas vivre sans les
insectes des êtres fascinants et
fragiles dont il faut prendre soin selon
une étude de 2017 les trois quarts des
insectes volants présents en Allemagne
ont disparu en près de 30 ans diminution
de leur habitat et pollution d'origine
humaine des animations sont proposées
avec lopie dans cette maison pour
sensibiliser le public à ses
problématiques
ce qui est absolument inédit aujourd'hui
c'est que on a une espèce sur la planète
qui est devenue absolument prépondérante
qui est l'homme et qui a un impact tel
qu'en 100 ans il est capable de
provoquer cette crise d'extinction qui
est quasiment comparable aux crises
d'extinction qu'on a pu connaître dans
les temps géologiques le premier levier
que les personnes ont c'est la première
chose qu'ils peuvent faire c'est agir
directement sur leur jardin laisser un
peu faire laisser un peu de sauvage dans
le jardin c'est déjà une action qui est
extrêmement importante et presque
militante aujourd'hui une visite ludique
et interactive pour mieux prendre
conscience des enjeux liés à ces espèces
chaque année le pissensibilise environ
20 000 personnes par tout en France un
travail de fourmis pour permettre aux
petits et aux grands d'observer d'un œil
nouveau les insectes